GLENN FRANKEL: Let me do
some Google analytics.
How many of you have seen
"The Searchers"?
All right.
We got pretty much
the whole group.
And anybody here from Texas?
Ever hear of Cynthia
Ann Parker?
Yes.
All right.
Well, that's a start.
I had never heard of
Cynthia Ann Parker.
I grew up in Rochester,
New York.
So Texas was just what I saw in
a John Ford movie, mostly.
But I did know "The Searchers,"
and I wasn't the
only one, of course.
A lot of people saw it when
they were young, including
Steven Spielberg and George
Lucas and Martin Scorsese.
And it was a really formative
film for them and launched
them on their careers.
It was a formative
film for me too.
I ended up being a journalist
and saw it again several times
along the way.
And I was moved by it.
It's a very powerful--
for those of you who have seen
it know it's a very powerful
and unsettling film
in many ways.
And after spending years abroad
and coming back to the
US and then going out to
Stanford University to teach
journalism, I wanted to
do an American book.
And "The Searchers" seemed
like a great
subject for a book.
Again, I got on Google.
Google has a lot to do with
getting me started on this,
because I got on and noticed
right away first of all, there
wasn't a mainstream book
about "The Searchers."
But with another click or
two, I found that--
I thought OK, so I'll do a
making of the movie book, a
fairly standard thing--
John Ford, John Wayne.
That'll be fine.
But it only took a couple more
clicks searching around to
find Cynthia Ann Parker and to
find that, to my surprise,
this incredible movie was
actually loosely based on
something that had really
happened, a nine-year-old girl
being kidnapped by Comanches
in Texas.
So that just sort of changed--
it didn't change the focus,
but it just sort of expanded
the whole thing from being
making of the movie to something
that covered,
frankly, in the end, 150 years
and about not only going to
Hollywood and then to Monument
Valley, but also to Texas and
many, many more archives.
And it became a long and
fascinating trek for me.
But it all begins
back in 1836.
So Cynthia Ann Parker was part
of a family that's kind of one
of your iconic American
pioneer families.
They started out in Maryland
and Virginia, before the
Revolutionary War.
Her grandfather fights in
the Revolutionary War.
Then they head first
down to Georgia.
Then they go to Tennessee,
then to Illinois.
You could kind of say
they failed West.
Each place they went
they tried to farm.
They tried to establish
a life.
Some of them were preachers.
A lot of them were farmers.
They were both actually.
And when they ran out of soil,
or they wore out their
welcome, they would
move further west.
They were sort of kicking down
the doors of Western expansion
the whole time.
And eventually a couple of them,
specifically, her uncle
James goes down to Texas at a
time when it's still a Mexican
colony, and where white folks,
American folks, can come and
get a large quantity of land for
just a few hundred dollars
and start new.
And so Uncle James heads
back up to Illinois.
And in the end, about 40 members
of the family had on
down, along with dozens of
other folks from a couple
rural communities in Illinois.
And they make their
way to Texas.
The Parkers set up
a farming area.
Well, they split up.
Some of them head to basically
where most of the white
settlement was in East Texas.
But some of them, with good old
Uncle James, moved further
to the north and west into the
beginning of Indian territory.
The land's good there.
There's not a lot of competition
to farm there.
And they build themselves
a fortified settlement.
But a lot of things happened in
1836 in Texas, as some of
you may know, including the
Alamo and the defeat of Santa
Ana, and the declaration
of a republic.
They had to leave their
fortified settlement for
several weeks.
And by the time they got back
to it, they were running out
of time to plant.
They planted in a hurry.
They left the gates of the
settlement wide open, the sort
of fortified area.
And sooner or later, a
group of Comanches
and Kiowa come down.
This is in May 1836.
And we don't know exactly
what triggered what.
They didn't have CCTV or video
cameras recording the results
on the stockade walls.
But the Indians killed five men
there, including Cynthia
Ann's father, her uncle,
her grandfather.
And they abducted five young
people, including
nine-year-old Cynthia Ann.
And they hauled them off
to Comanche territory.
And Uncle James survived
that raid.
He helped take folks
back to safety.
And then he set out to try
to find these kids.
He had help along the way.
Sometimes he had a large
group with him.
Sometimes it was just him.
And eventually he helped
recover four of them.
But he never found
Cynthia Ann.
And she ended up spending 24
years with the Comanches.
She married a Comanche.
She had three Comanche
children.
She became for all intents
and purposes a Comanche.
The Comanches, if they'd had a
team of psychologists, they
couldn't have come up with a
better system for taking young
people and Indianizing them.
These sort of tough young men
would haul you off and
brutalize you on the way home.
But when you got there, if you
were young and of a certain
age, you would be adopted by a
Comanche family, because birth
rate was low.
People died.
Infant mortality was high.
So Cynthia Ann was, as far as we
know, probably adopted by a
family and treated
very warmly.
And so within a year or so, most
of these kids would lose
their Anglo-Saxon roots,
whatever they were, including
their language.
And they would really
become Comanches.
And she spent 24 years
with them.
Meanwhile, as I say, Uncle James
spent something like
seven or eight years
looking for her.
He wrote a rather plaintive
narrative about it in the
early 1840s, where he cast
himself as one of the sort of
classic figures from the
American West, the man who
knows Indians.
He knows their lore.
He knows their customs.
Often the man who knows Indians
is also an Indian
fighter or sometimes
an Indian hater.
And Uncle James was certainly
all of that.
And he was unsuccessful.
I mean the other four kids, as
I say, they got them back
slowly but surely, but
not Cynthia Ann.
And so his book is this effort
to explain his own version of
what happened during the raid,
why the doors and the gates
were open, all those things.
So right from the beginning,
people are taking this basic
simple story of the abduction of
a little girl, and they're
starting to retell it and to
embroider it a bit, change the
parts they don't like, parts
that don't fit their own
sensibility, and then giving
us another version.
And Uncle James, in that sense,
is one of the first
storytellers.
When I first thought I'd do
the book, I thought well,
there'll be one chapter near the
beginning about captivity
narratives, because
"The Searchers"
is a captivity narrative.
Well, I had no idea, though,
as I started expanding my
concept of what this was, how
important captivity narratives
were in early America.
Turns out they were like our
first literary genre,
distinctly American genre.
They date back to the 1680s.
Mary Rowlandson, a woman who was
kidnapped with two of her
children by Narragansset Indians
in New England, had
the first best seller
in America.
And it was about her
time in captivity.
And their stories, and at the
time Cynthia Ann was kidnapped
in 1836, three of the four
bestselling books were James
Fenimore Cooper novels,
including "The Last of the
Mohicans." And all of those
books had captivity narrative
themes running through them.
And then the fourth one was
about Mary Jemison, who was
kidnapped by Seneca Indians
actually, not far from where I
grew up in Rochester,
New York.
So this really inflamed
people's imaginations.
The idea of women and children
being hauled off into the
forest primeval by these men,
by these savages, became one
of those sort of scary but in
some ways attractive themes.
There's a lot of psychosexual
connotations to being taken
off by native men.
And one of the sort of themes
that came out of that is
something called "a fate
worse than death"--
the idea that women could be
taken by Indians and forced to
have sex with an Indian or to
marry an Indian, whether
willingly or unwillingly.
This was one of the
things that made
these books so popular.
And again, there's one of the
themes of the conquest of the
West, because if the indigenous
peoples are taking
our families and destroying them
in this way, we need to
conquer them to protect
our families.
And it becomes one of the
justifications for a lot of
imperial action, including
in Texas.
Because once you get the
Comanches and the Texans at
war with each other, Comanches
are abducting a lot of people.
They need to abduct people to
run-- they've got a great
economy of horsemanship
and buffalo.
And they have a low
birth rate.
And so they need people.
Mostly they're kidnapping
people from Mexico.
But when the Texans start
settling in the area, they
become fair game as well.
And there's a 40-year war
between Texans and
Comanches going on.
It's the longest war really ever
fought on American soil.
And it's a very intimate war.
They didn't have drones.
You looked at your enemy
when you killed him.
And families weren't just like
the collateral damage.
Oh, we're really sorry that
we killed your child.
We didn't mean too.
Uh uh.
That wasn't what it was about.
It was very much about
destroying the
other side's family.
It was about crushing
their culture.
It was about conquest.
And this thing--
as I say, this was a
40-year struggle.
And Cynthia Ann, in many ways,
became sort of a symbol of
this for the Texans.
She became this mythic white
Comanche princess.
They didn't know
where she was.
There were a couple of sightings
over the years.
Some were imaginary, fiction.
Others were real.
But they couldn't find her, and
the Comanches would hide
her when the time came.
And as I say, she grew up
to become a Comanche.
She had three children.
And so the story was told.
It was kind of bubbling
out there.
And then in 1860--
and so we're talking 24 years
after she's first abducted--
she's involved in
another raid.
Only this time, not Indians
attacking her home.
It's US Cavalry and Texas
Rangers attacking her village.
And they kill the people
around her again.
Strange men come, speaking
a language she doesn't
understand and kill
a lot of people.
And they're about to kill her,
but somebody notices that this
woman who looks all Comanche
has blue eyes.
And so they don't shoot her.
And she kind of cries out
Americano, Americano.
She speaks no English.
She speaks a bit of Spanish
and Comanche.
So they take her and
her little baby
daughter who's with her.
And they take her back to Camp
Cooper in North Texas.
And they figure out pretty
quickly that she's got to be
the legendary Cynthia
Ann Parker.
And they get ahold of her Uncle
Isaac, and he comes out
in the buckboard from
about 90 miles away.
And she listens to him talk to
the commander and get the
circumstances.
And at one point, she pops up
and hits herself in the chest,
saying "Me, Cinny Ann.
Me, Cinny Ann."
So it was clear who she was.
Uncle Isaac's going
to take her home.
She doesn't want to go.
She's got two Comanche
sons back somewhere.
And she's got a Comanche
husband.
And that's her life.
But she has no choice.
So she begs the commander, if
you see my sons, be sure to
find them and-- you
know, call me up.
Let me know.
And she goes off with
her Uncle Isaac.
And not surprisingly,
it's not a very good
fit after 24 years.
It was very hard for people
who had been captive, who
crossed that sort of invisible
border, if you will, from one
culture to another, and cultures
who were at war with
each other.
Very hard to come back.
Her family was actually-- her
Texan family was actually very
kind to her.
But they couldn't grasp what had
happened to her, nor the
fact that she wasn't grateful to
be restored to a Christian
redemptive situation.
They couldn't quite get it.
And she, of course, didn't
understand them.
So for a while she's kind
of a minor celebrity.
They take her to the state
legislature, and they get her
a parcel of land
and an annuity.
They show her off.
There's one sort of sad scene of
her being put on a soapbox
outside a store in Fort Worth
and kids being let out of
school early to go
look at her.
And she's crying.
Because it's very hard for her
to process any of this.
There are a couple photos of
her where she looks like a
deer in the headlights,
really.
So eventually to her family,
she becomes not so much the
celebrity but an
embarrassment.
They don't know what
to do with her.
And eventually, they pack her
off to a family sawmill in
East Texas about
100 miles away.
And we don't know exactly
when she died.
There's no obituary of
this mini-celebrity.
And there's no real sense of
what had happened to her
during those 24 years when she
was with the Comanches.
She doesn't leave a narrative.
She doesn't give-- nobody really
ever does a thorough
job of interviewing her.
Which, in a way, is great
for the myth, right?
Because people can just imagine
whatever they want.
Texans can imagine whatever
they want about her life.
And Comanches, turns
out, do the same.
They have their own oral version
of her life and times.
And theirs is very
romanticized.
And in the Texans' version,
she's beaten up, and all this.
But neither one is based on
anything near that we could
begin to call fact.
And what happens is eventually
her little girl dies, probably
of typhus or one of the diseases
raging through
periodically.
And soon afterward, Cynthia
Ann dies as well.
In the legend, it all takes
place in 1864, and she dies of
a broken heart, immediately
after Prairie Flower, her
daughter, dies.
But the fact is there's--
a researcher I know came up with
the 1870 census and found
Cynthia Ann's name in the 1870
census from Anderson County.
So we know she lived
that long.
But we know she died
miserably.
Even though her sons and the
Comanche community was maybe
100, 150 miles away, that could
have been the other side
of the moon, because
they were at war.
At one point, the family gets
a translator to come by or
someone, a scout, who
knows Comanche.
And Cynthia Ann just goes
crazy, because she has
somebody to talk to.
But all she wants from this guy,
Coho Smith, is begging--
she begs him to take her back
to Comancheria, to her home.
She'll give them anything.
They will.
She assures him, the
village will give
him anything he wants.
They'll give him horses.
They'll give him women.
Anything, because her husband
will pay for her ransom.
And Smith basically says to
her, if I take you, your
people will kill me.
And she assures him
they won't.
And he says, and if they don't
kill me, once I get back here,
these folks will kill me.
Because you're just not
allowed to do it.
There's no passport you can have
that allows you to cross
this border.
And so she never gets back.
She dies in obscurity.
And what she doesn't know, and
really the only saving grace
of all this, is that one of her
Comanche sons, the only
one who survives to adulthood,
whose name is Quanah, becomes
a rather noteworthy and
important person in Native
American history.
He spent the first half of his
life being a nomadic warrior
on the High Plains in Texas.
But then when Comanche power
is really finally crushed
around 1875, and the last
Comanche straggle in to the
Indian agency in what's now
Oklahoma, he comes in.
But unlike many of the others,
he gets a pretty good sense of
what the situation is.
And he becomes kind of a
middleman conciliator, part
politician, part businessman,
and becomes their spokesman.
They're only down to-- the
Comanches were down to less
than 3,000 people by then.
And they were doomed, really.
It was much more dangerous in
a way to be a ward of the
American government than it had
been to be an enemy of the
American government
on the Plains.
Because they were out not to
kill you, but to destroy your
culture, and to make you into
little white people.
That was the way that the
progressives, who were the
Indians' best friends,
thought was the only
path to survival then.
Get rid of their language.
Cut off their braids.
Put them in little white
people's clothes.
Send them off to schools, where
they would be taught
those things.
And get this whole Comanche
thing out of their system.
Make them Christians.
Forget their own religion.
All of it.
Monogamy, land.
Eventually, they were
given land.
They'd never farmed.
They didn't know how to farm.
They didn't want to farm.
But all this went on.
Well, Quanah eventually took
his mother's last name--
Parker-- took the family name
and made contact with the
Texan Parkers.
And remember, all this time,
Cynthia Ann's basically got
two families now, right?
She's got these Comanches
family, but the original Texan
family exists also.
And Quanah makes efforts to
contact them and eventually is
successful.
So he's a very interesting
figure over a
long period of time.
He befriends Teddy Roosevelt
and also some wealthy white
ranchers in Texas, who
are taking their
cattle through Oklahoma.
And they lease to these wealthy
guys grasslands while
they're going through.
So the Comanches do
reasonably well.
Quanah builds a big house
called the Star House.
He put 12 stars on the roof so
he could outrank any general
who showed up.
He had Teddy Roosevelt
to dinner.
Teddy Roosevelt promises him one
night that he's going to
bring buffalo back
to Oklahoma.
And sure enough, like a couple
years later, a train pulls up
with 15 bison from
the Bronx Zoo.
And they unload them.
And they take them up north of
where Quanah's house is.
And those bison--
there are now more than 600 of
them in the Wichita Mountains
game reserve.
So that's kind of like Quanah's
legacy, that kind of
thing, keeping his
people alive.
Some of them didn't love him,
because they thought he was
like a sell-out and a white guy,
because he's half white.
As for the white folks, they
admired him because he was
half-white.
He's very smart.
That's because he's
half-white, right?
So he's the "noble
savage" for them.
He's the good Indian,
not the barbarian.
But the reason he's a good
Indian is because he's
actually half-white.
And he goes along with this
to a great extent.
And he cites his mother and
who she was and her being
white as the reason why he is
this great conciliator.
So he's a storyteller.
He doesn't write a book
or anything like that.
But Quanah is telling the
story of his mother to
explain who he is.
So it's a very rich kind
of mythic thing
building up over the years.
He dies in 1911.
The story takes a bit of a rest
here and there, but the
two sides of the family
begin to get together.
And in 1936, the hundredth
celebration of Texas
independence and also of this
raid, the two sides of the
family get together at the site
of the original raid.
The State of Texas builds
a new replica of
the original fort.
And they reenact the raid.
The Comanche Parkers play the
Comanches, and the white
Parkers play the
white settlers.
And there they are.
So it's 100 years, and they
sell-- and incidentally, it
was in Groesbeck, Texas.
There was an ice cream
parlor there.
And they name the ice cream
after Cynthia Ann.
So it's already Americans
reinventing this stuff, having
a good time with it, but using
it to explain who they are.
And then it drifts on, in many
ways, told, and the families
begin to have reunions
and get together.
Meanwhile, I pick it up again
in the early 1950s, when a
Hollywood screenwriter and
western novelist named Alan
LeMay comes along.
And Alan's in his late 40s,
and he's been working in
Hollywood for a while.
He's written a bunch
of western novels
that did pretty well.
But at one point, Alan needed
more money than he was making
from the novels.
So he starts doing movies.
And he works for Cecil
B. DeMille.
And it's kind of a hand
to mouth existence.
And he's up there in the Texas
panhandle doing a B movie that
he's actually directing, when
he hears about Quanah Parker
and Cynthia Ann.
And he travels down
to East Texas and
meets some of the Parkers.
Curiously, they remember that he
talked to them not so much
about Cynthia Ann, but
about Uncle James.
He was interested in what the
deal was with Uncle James,
what he tried to do,
how did it work.
And Alan then begins
to work on a novel.
As I say, he's worn out.
He's tired of Hollywood.
And he wants to get back to
what he really knows best,
which is writing westerns.
And he writes "The Searchers."
And "The Searchers"--
he changes some things-- a lot
of things-- from the original
story, including the names of
the central characters.
He moves the date up from
1836 to 1868, to
after the Civil War.
That allows him to play off that
a little, but I think he
did a lot because he
liked the munitions
better after the war.
There were repeating rifles
and things like that.
Alan knew a lot about horses.
He knew a lot about cattle.
He knew a lot about munitions.
And he just kind of did
what he wanted to do.
And he took about 60--
in his notes, you find like 65
different captivity narratives
stories listed.
And he smushed the parts
together that interested him.
But the basic thing
is Cynthia Ann.
And he creates two searchers--
the uncle and then
a younger sort of
nephew, adopted nephew.
And they go and search
for seven years.
And the book did rather well.
And then some folks came along,
looking for a novel, or
looking for a story to give
to a man named John Ford.
And they came up with
"The Searchers."
So let me stop there
and get into John
Ford just for a minute.
John Ford's one of
those folks.
He won four Academy Awards for
Best Director, more than
anyone else has ever won.
He was one of the great
directors of his time.
But I don't know, how many folks
here have seen John,
other than "The Searchers"--
have seen John Ford films
over the years?
The older crowd.
Yeah.
I have too.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Ford didn't invent
the Western.
But his career begins in 1917.
His first movie he directs
is a silent in 1917.
It's called "Tornado."
It's a Western.
And time and time again, through
the course of his
career, he comes back
to Westerns.
He never won an Academy
Award for a Western.
They were considered kind of,
you know, popular genre, a
little cheap.
They were entertainment.
He won for "Grapes of Wrath"
or "The Informer," really
very-- which are wonderful
films, incidentally.
"How Green Was My Valley,"
"The Quiet Man."
But he always came
back to Westerns.
And along the way, he acquired
a sort of stable of people he
would work with, who would
put up with him.
He was a real dictator.
He was a lifelong alcoholic.
He was incredibly abusive to
members of his own family and
frankly to his cast and crew.
But they were loyal to him in
part because it was steady
work and in part because they
knew when they were working
with Ford, they were working
on something special.
And he makes some Westerns
that really are quite
enduring. "Stagecoach," which is
the movie that breaks out a
young actor, B movie actor named
John Wayne, and makes
him a star.
And Wayne becomes part of Ford's
entourage, if you will.
They'd been drinking buddies
before then.
But now Ford uses him
again and again.
And Wayne, who's a very loyal
guy, is always there
when Ford needs him.
And so by the time we're talking
about "The Searchers,"
and this is now 1954, Ford is 60
years old, and he's a mess.
When you're 60 years old in
those days, and you're
drinking and smoking at the
level he was, you're heading
for the end pretty quickly.
And he just had gallbladder
surgery.
He'd just been working on a film
called "Mr. Roberts," and
it'd ended poorly.
There's a scene, actually at
the beginning of the book,
where he punches his star, Henry
Fonda-- who was another
dear friend and drinking
buddy--
punches him in the
face one day.
Because he's upset, because
Fonda's upset with the way
Ford's directing the movie.
Ford's on it too, and
he's drinking.
So things end badly with
"Mr. Roberts" for him.
They take him off the film,
basically, and give it to
Mervyn LeRoy.
He comes out of the hospital.
And, as often happened in Ford's
career, some of his
loyal friends basically-- they
don't stage an intervention.
Nobody intervenes
with John Ford.
But they do rescue him in the
sense that they come up with
"The Searchers." they
find this novel.
A guy named Merian C.
Cooper, who was
Ford's business partner--
we think all the independent
film companies started today.
But that's not really true.
The indies started long ago.
And Ford and Cooper had
one called Argosy.
And Cooper reads this
book, and thinks
it's perfect for Ford.
And Ford agrees.
And Cooper not only does that,
he lines up a money man named
Cornelius Vanderbilt Whitney.
So that's Vanderbilt
and Whitney, right?
Two huge American fortunes.
And he wants to get
into the movies.
He wants to make movies.
He wants to get his name out.
He's interested in Hollywood
starlets.
He puts up the money.
They get Warner Brothers to put
up about a third and to
agree to distribute it.
And off they go.
And Ford takes his crew--
the wranglers, the stuntmen, the
camera people, all these
folks who work in the John Ford
stock company, if you
will, as they were called.
And he goes back to his favorite
location, which is
Monument Valley.
All right, who's been there?
Have you been to Texas?
Does Monument Valley look
a lot like Texas?
Nah.
Monument Valley looks like
we think, growing up in
Rochester, New York, how you
might think Texas should look.
It's big and tall and vertical
and dry and relentless and
very dramatic.
Texas doesn't look like that.
But the opening scene of "The
Searchers" says "Texas 1868."
The panel goes away.
The door opens.
And you're in Monument Valley.
Because that's where Ford liked
to film his Westerns.
He liked to film them, because
it was visually such a
stunning place.
It was such a dramatic
setting.
So you had all this literally
monumental
geography as the backdrop.
Its a little like Shakespeare,
going to the Globe Theatre and
telling you he's doing a Danish
prince there, that
you're in Denmark, or you're
in Italy with star-crossed
lovers or something.
Shakespeare did them all at the
Globe Theatre and set them
in different places, but they're
all taking place in
the same place.
And Ford did about, in the
end, about seven films in
Monument Valley.
This one is the most beautiful
in many ways.
He's got VistaVision, this
technique that they
used for a few years.
So they're filming
with two cameras.
And the colors are wonderful.
And the whole drama
of it is great.
And he sets to work.
And remember, as I say,
he's 60 years old.
He's made many Westerns over
the years, but Ford's the
great myth maker.
You know Westerns are just
good stories, right?
I mean, cowboys and Indians
or good guys and bad guys.
There are shoot-em-ups.
There's horses.
Ford himself once said that
filming a man on a horse is
the most cinematic thing I can
think of, just riding along a
beautiful spot of land.
That's movie making.
So we had that going.
And Ford, as I say, had
become the master of
that over the years.
So this gave him the opportunity
really to
rehabilitate himself and
to prove himself again.
And they go out there
to Monument Valley.
The other advantage of it is
it's 650 miles from Hollywood.
It's very hard for the studio
suits from Warner Brothers to
get out there and keep
an eye on things.
And Ford goes to work.
And he makes a classic American
movie, starring John
Wayne, the classic American
Western icon.
So we've had the Man Who Knows
Indians before, and we've had
the fate worse than death.
Now we have the great Indian
fighter, the great laconic
lone gunman.
And John Wayne embodies that.
He's very charismatic in "The
Searchers." He's a very
powerful figure.
But what's so interesting, I
think, is that at the same
time Ford's giving us the
Western in all of its iconic,
mythic glory, he's undermining
it a little here and there.
And especially with Wayne,
because here we have the hero,
yet as the movie goes on, the
hero is a complex figure.
I'm not going to go into too
many details about the plot,
of course, for those of you
who haven't seen it.
But there's a raid.
People are killed.
And the uncle and a nephew--
a fiction-- go out and try
to retrieve, rescue, this
nine-year-old girl.
But as time goes on, just
as with Cynthia Ann, the
nine-year-old girl becomes a
16-year-old woman and becomes
the wife of a Comanche brave--
in fact, the warrior who
had led the raid.
And so for the uncle, this
morphs from an effort to
rescue his little niece into
something much darker.
He's planning to kill her.
He's planning to kill her
because she's had sex with
Indians, voluntarily or not.
She's been polluted somehow.
She's unclean.
But at the same time, and this
is where I think the artistry
of Wayne comes in, he's
not happy about this.
It's not like oh, well, I guess
I'll kill her, and just
rides off to go find
her to do that.
He's troubled by it.
It's not easy for him.
He can't process all the
things going on.
That versus finding Debbie--
the little girl.
It's a mess with him.
And Wayne, I think most of us
who remember John Wayne think
of him as that sort of clunky
guy with the toupee making the
same movie over and over again
in the late '60s and
pro-Vietnam and just kind
of that right wing guy.
And to go back and to see
"Searchers" or to see, for
that matter, "Stagecoach" in
1939 or "Red River" in 1948,
that's a different actor.
That's a real actor.
That's a movie actor.
John Wayne invented a character
named John Wayne.
He didn't write his own parts,
but he invented the guy who
played them, the way he walks,
the slow talking, that sense
of being charming but
also menacing.
All that is built out of
watching other actors, out of
watching a stuntman here and a
little bit there, from Harry
Carey, Sr., who had worked with
Ford and Wayne had seen
all his films.
This was an invention.
And in many ways, "Searchers"
is, I would argue,
the epitome of this.
It's his greatest role.
He certainly thought it was
one of the greatest ones.
He named his last son Ethan
after the character he plays.
The uncle is called
Ethan Edwards.
So Wayne's doing this.
The role is complex.
Ford's giving us, as I say, this
great character who we
identify with.
And we want him to
succeed, right?
He's John Wayne!
But at the same time,
he's a psychopath.
And he's an Indian hater.
And he's a racist.
And he's trying--
and it's all going on within
this one character.
And the fictional adopted nephew
who's with him stays on
the search for all seven years--
and it goes on for
seven years--
to stop him.
Martin is his name.
And Martin is there specifically
to save his
little adopted sister
from the uncle.
And Martin becomes sort of the
moral center of the film.
And he comments on the uncle and
the increasing psychosis
and crazy things the
uncle's doing.
And so it's a very rich mix.
It's not simple.
I got to tell you in researching
the film--
the film, the book--
it was easier to research
Cynthia Ann Parker and Quanah
Parker and all that in the 19th
century than it was to
get a lot of material about
John Ford making "The
Searchers."
His papers are at Indiana
University, but Ford didn't
write a lot of stuff down.
He pretended that his Westerns
were like just a piece of work
that he did, very workmanlike.
If you asked him questions about
the kind of things we're
talking about now,
he'd just laugh.
When I think about who I'd like
to interview, if I could
bring back someone, I'd love
to interview John Wayne.
He was such a generous,
nice guy.
And we'd have a good time.
Ford, I don't know.
He would just like abuse you.
And he wouldn't answer any
questions, not in a
straightforward way.
Even Peter Bogdanovich, who
interviewed him and who he
liked a lot, nah.
You don't get much out of him.
He did say to Bogdanovich
at one point about "The
Searchers," it's a psychological
epic.
So figure out what that
means for yourself.
It's very clear what
he's talking about.
So the movie ends-- as I
say, I'm not going to
tell you how it ends--
but one of the things I
discovered in trying to figure
out if Ford doesn't leave me a
lot of notes, how do I know
why he made the decisions he
made during the movie?
And the one way you can figure
it out is to take the final
shooting script, by a guy
named Frank Nugent--
who incidentally, earlier in
his life, was a "New York
Times" film reviewer, who went
out to Hollywood and failed at
a few things.
And then Ford hired him to
be his pet screenwriter.
Look at Nugent's final shooting
script, which is
very, very good.
But then look at what's
actually in the movie.
And you find that repeatedly,
Ford takes out dialogue,
exposition, anything where
characters are explaining
themselves.
And he just leaves you the
sort of visual narrative.
You have to figure out.
We have to decide how the
uncle's feeling, what the
uncle's really going to do.
We have to decide all these
things in the course of the
film, because they don't
explain them.
In the script, some of them are
explained very thoroughly.
And Ford takes it out.
And I would argue that that's
one of the reasons "The
Searchers" is such a great
movie, that kind of ambiguity,
that kind of visual
storytelling,
leaving it to you.
So many people know the movie so
well that sometimes when I
do these talks, they'll ask
very, very detailed questions.
You know, well, do you think
that Debbie, the little girl
who the uncle was searching
for could be his
illegitimate daughter?
Maybe.
All these things that were
clear or clearer in the
written script are gone,
and you have
to decide for yourself.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sort of a
quick question.
How closely does the script
mirror the book?
GLENN FRANKEL: The book is the
source of a lot of things, and
some of the dialogue, because
Alan LeMay was a screenwriter.
And he wrote good dialogue.
And he couldn't help
but write.
But some things are changed
pretty dramatically.
For one thing, Martin, the
nephew, is the sort of central
character in the book.
And his development, his
evolution from being a callow
youth to being a very
experienced back woodsman, and
again his quest, his moral quest
to find and save his
sister, that's the center
of the movie.
The uncle is there.
He's important.
The interplay between them
is very important.
But it's a different thing.
And the reason is quite
clear for that.
Ford had John Wayne.
And so Nugent, who'd written
for Wayne before, writes a
screenplay where John Wayne's
the central figure.
The book begins with the
Comanche raid on the family.
That's the opening scene
of the book.
That's a great opening scene
for a movie, right?
But that's not how they
open the movie.
They open the movie with the
uncle riding up to the family
home before the raid.
And you're introducing this
somewhat mysterious dark
character, both charming, but
we don't know what he's been
doing since the Civil War ended
three years earlier.
Clearly he's been doing things
that are illegal.
He's got a lot of money.
He's mysterious.
He won't talk about what was
happening, that sort of thing.
He's got a medal that seems
to have come from Mexico.
We don't know what this
guy's been up.
That's all different from-- as
I say, the raid scene is in
there later, but it doesn't
open that way.
The uncle is a much
heavier figure.
And in the book, all these
psychosexual things are there,
but not quite as strongly.
The uncle is not determined
to kill her.
He doesn't care that
much about her.
He's out seeking vengeance
for the death of
members of his family.
But he doesn't decide
to kill her.
He never resolves to do that.
He doesn't care.
And Martin is there to find
her and bring her back.
But what Ford and Nugent do is
they take that, and they just
jack it right up, because the
uncle is-- it is an honor
killing that he's on, just as
bad as anything in the Middle
East that you can imagine.
He's going to kill
this little girl,
because she's been violated.
And this is his notion
of justice.
That's Ford and Nugent.
It's not in the novel.
So it is a very good
novel incidentally.
And it's fun to read, if
you haven't read it.
It's very grim though.
That's the other thing.
There's no humor.
There's no humor in the novel.
And Ford puts in a lot of his
sort of corn ball humor and
community scenes, because that's
what Ford always did.
He loved that.
But also he had to leaven the
grim relentlessness of this
seven-year search.
So it feels very different.
LeMay himself, having worked
with Cecil B. DeMille and some
other maniacs in Hollywood, knew
he didn't want to work
with John Ford.
Not that Ford would've
asked him to write
the screenplay anyway.
Ford always used Nugent.
He used his own sort of tame
scriptwriter guy he had
control over.
But LeMay walked away from it.
I met LeMay's son, Dan, and he
said my dad said he didn't
want to have anything
to do with it.
And I would really love to know
what LeMay thought of the
movie, but I don't know.
He never wrote about it.
He never said a word.
He took the money.
He got a really good pay-out
for the book from Warners.
And that was it.
They bought his silence.
So "The Searchers," as you know,
when "The Searchers"
came out, it was considered like
another pretty good John
Wayne cowboy and Indian movie.
It got decent reviews,
made some
money, and then it vanished.
Ford and Wayne were
disappointed.
It didn't get nominated
for anything.
But they moved on.
And it really took another
generation to come along and
begin to see the subtleties
and the layers of what was
going on in "The Searchers."
And it took Spielberg and
Lucas and these guys not only
to quote from the movie in
their own films, but also to
talk about the movie as to how
important it was.
And movies like "Taxi Driver"
basically, I think, are a
modern New York version of
"Searchers" in a way,
searching for this young woman
in the "other" world, that
sort of thing.
So the movie begins to take
on a new life, if
you will, over time.
And it's uncanny.
One critic said that just in the
same way that all modern
American literature flows from
Huckleberry Finn, one way or
another, all modern cinema of
this generation of Spielberg,
et cetera, flows from
"The Searchers."
It's still an unsettling
movie to see it today.
The great quote I love from a
critic named David Thompson,
who doesn't love Ford generally,
but he loves "The
Searchers." And he said, "Every
time I see it, I don't
know how it's going to end."
Because there's just
a lot going on.
And we don't really know what
the uncle's going to do, or
how Martin's going
to stop him.
Or if Martin's going to
be able to stop him.
And I think I'll leave
it there, in terms of
talking about it.
But that's how I feel about it.
I feel--
and gosh knows how many times
I've seen it now.
But it's always thrilling, and
it's always unsettling,
because it's about all these
complicated themes.
And it's about race and sex.
And my book, the only other
thing I'd say--
my book turned out to be--
the subtitle is "The Making of
an American Legend." It's how
a story, a simple story, gets
told and retold by every
generation and reimagined.
And as I said earlier, they
embroider some parts, and they
take out some stuff they don't
like, depending on their own
needs and their own
sensibility.
And so in a way, that's
what's happened.
"Searchers," the movie, is
another manifestation of that.
And in its own humble
way, my book is too.
This isn't the last word on the
movie or Cynthia Ann or
any of that.
It's just my version in 2013.
But as you can imagine, it was
an enormously satisfying thing
to work on.
I stumbled into it basically.
And I'm awfully glad I did,
because this film and the
story behind it is still a
very important American
foundational myth about how we
live and what we draw-- the
meaning we draw from
these things.
So thanks for listening.
Let's talk a little bit.
Questions?
Comments?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We talked about the
abduction narrative being so
central to American literature
and history.
When did those types of
stories-- how late into the
later 1800s, early 1900s
did that-- or early
20th century go?
What's the latest example?
GLENN FRANKEL: The captivity
narrative kind of reinvents
itself every generation
or two, also.
Generally what happens is, in
New England, for example,
after New England was settled,
and the Native Americans were
no longer a threat.
They were either wiped
out or tamed.
So first you get a few like Mary
Rowlandson that are about
these evil savages
and horrifying.
Then you get the sort of noble
savage version of it later,
when they basically have been
neutered, and they're no
longer a threat.
And so you get a whole new range
of literature coming out
in New England.
But then when you get down to
Texas, and you get another
round of heavy duty
war, the narrative
becomes dark and grim.
And for the most part, we're
talking true stories.
James Fenimore Cooper's
writing novels.
There are dime novels,
dime Westerns.
So you have all this fiction.
But it's based on
real stories.
And you get another genre.
So Rachel Plummer, who I haven't
mentioned, but who was
one of the five people kidnapped
with Cynthia Ann.
She writes a narrative
of her time.
It's a short one.
She's Uncle James's daughter.
And she dies soon after
she's returned.
She writes one.
And Sarah Ann Horn, an English
woman who comes over, she
writes one.
And there's like 5, 10, 20.
They go on and on.
And so it gets another cycle.
And then of course as the
Western emerges as a literary
genre, and then as stage plays
and Buffalo Bill and all that,
and then the movies
come along.
And remember, the movies come
along right when the real West
is kind of finished, just
around the same time.
So already, even the first
Western movies are depicting a
place that doesn't
exist anymore.
They're depicting
the fantastical
version of that place.
And they use the captivity
narrative.
They reverse it sometimes.
There's the classic Indian young
woman who rescues the
white guy, and she turns out
to be the most adept with
horses and all this stuff.
Ah, but it turns out she's
actually a white girl who was
captured as a little girl and
made into an Indian, and she's
the greatest Indian of all.
You have all those kinds of
themes going back and forth.
And so, right up to now, I mean
"Dances with Wolves" is a
captivity narrative.
And in fact, in the original,
it's Comanches, not Sioux.
But Kevin Costner changed it, I
think, for cinematic reasons
or where he wanted to shoot.
So you have this thing going
on, just like the Western
itself has lost a lot of
momentum in the last couple of
generations, really starting
with Vietnam, the captivity
narrative has lost some of it.
Or it's had to morph.
You can do captivity narratives
and quests in any
genre, really, in the end.
It's a theme that goes back
to the "Iliad." That's a
captivity narrative.
They go to get Helen.
So it's from the beginning
and it's still there.
AUDIENCE: I can think
of at least two
Newbery prize winners.
And there's a captivity novel
in the middle of one of the
"Star Wars," right?
The mother is captured by
the Tusken raiders.
GLENN FRANKEL: Right.
Right.
Well, Lucas, he's all over it.
When Luke Skywalker's family's
house is burning in that scene
in the first "Star Wars," in the
first one that came out,
that's a direct quote from the
scene, the burning farmhouse
in "The Searchers," too.
Yeah, these themes have been
with us long before the
settlement of the American
West, in a sense.
But they become foundational
for us.
And again, especially because
they give us a reason to
justify conquest.
These folks are going to
kill our families.
We have to get them.
If they're going to take our
kids, we have to defeat them.
So it's like the imperial
justification
for the whole thing.
And we'll see, I can't think
of a book right now that
really sums it up, but
there'll be one.
Yeah?
Hey, John.
AUDIENCE: What kind of movies
did Ford make after this?
Did this affect the
way he looked at
things going forward?
GLENN FRANKEL: Ford was, as I
say, he was 60, 62, when he
was done with this.
He moved on.
He kept working.
Merian Cooper retired after
this, but Ford wouldn't and
couldn't retire.
He didn't know what else
he would do really.
So he hangs in there.
But I think he begins to
hit the downside of it.
He's not well.
He makes one more great Western,
I think, which is
"The Man Who Shot Liberty
Valance." And that's six or
seven years later.
He makes "The Last Hurrah,"
which is a pretty good movie,
a political movie,
about Boston.
And so, yeah, Ford's Irish, and
it's full of blarney, but
it's pretty good.
But things begin to fade a
little here and there.
He makes one more extraordinary
Western, I don't
really think it's a great
Western, but interesting, in
"Cheyenne Autumn." And that's
set in Monument Valley.
And it's about the Cheyenne
who try to escape from the
agencies in Oklahoma and get
back to their homeland.
It's a very sad movie.
It's his mea culpa, in a way,
because it's so warm and
emotional about Native Americans
in ways that none of
the previous movies had been,
including "Searchers."
So he makes another
10, 12, 15 movies.
Boy, he makes a horrible Western
called "Two Rode
Together" which has a Quanah
Parker character in it.
And it too is about captivity
narratives.
It's about bringing some
children, some young people,
back, but it doesn't go well.
He tells you after Cynthia Ann
comes back, what happens to
her, basically, in that movie,
and it's not good.
But the movie's slack, and it
uses some of the same scenes.
I don't know how you feel about
"Godfather 3." But I
always thought it wasn't
very good.
And in a way, "Two Rode
Together" is like John Ford's
"Godfather 3." It's got the
same kinds of things as
"Searchers," but it's
slack and bleagh.
It just doesn't work at all.
So that's it.
His last film is in the
late '60s, and he dies
of cancer in 1973.
And he had a heyday.
I mean, he had years.
He won those four Oscars
between 1935 and '52.
He also won two Oscars for
documentaries he filmed during
World War II.
So this guy is just--
he is a master, especially
of visual storytelling.
But he runs out of gas.
Well, look, thank
you very much.
It's a small group, but it
was fun talking to you.